what is algebra you guys know I have a
bit of an obsessive obsession with names
okay I'm going to go through this powers
of algebra it comes from an Arabic word
which means which means it means the
reunion of broken parts as Hannigan this
Arabic word it's an Arabic word that
means the reunion of broken parts in
fact in some languages in the world
today like Spanish this same phrases
come over to those language as well and
it's the phrase used for setting boards
after they are broken right they need to
be reunited and put together they're
broken but we can recombine them now as
maths goes right house roads often
experience with a lot of difficulty and
there's a good reason for that
okay algebra well compared to you guys
it's very very old it's very often been
around for hundreds of years in fact
it's been around for about it's about
500 years okay
but what do you think about it or the
mathematical scene algebra is super
super new right a lot of the mess that
we've been learning is thousands of
years old because people have discovered
it a long time ago right Pythagoras's
theorem for instance right we've learned
that and civilizations have known about
that for millennia right but algebra is
new comparatively it's only been hanging
around for a few centuries now not just
in terms of like society right but think
about like the human race if this has
only been around for this amount of time
human brains haven't evolved to
understand what algebra is it's new it's
an invention right so it should make
sense that we experience a little bit of
difficulty when we get to this right I
have
children and one of the first things
that you do if any of you have known
this younger Sibley's is you learn to
count counting we have been doing since
forever right tens of thousands of years
were very good at counting your brains
are built for counting your braids are
not built for this this is not easy
right so we should expect a bit of a
challenge but even though our brains
aren't built for this perhaps in fact
because they're not built for this
that's what makes this so powerful in
fact in the 1500s and you can write this
down next to your title is right in the
1500 algebra and is what we call a
game-changer it's a little bit like when
someone invented gunpowder right or the
bow and arrow and it changed warfare
forever right algebra change not just
math but problem-solving and the way
that situations are approached and
analyzed if it changed all of those
forever
he's the key idea right yesterday
yesterday I had a on a family lunch okay
and for lunch I went to Costco and I
bought some I've bought some pizzas
they're ridiculous things there are
they're so big you can't fit them in a
standard sized oven okay I had to slice
into pieces and pop it in to warm it up
there are no things I could barely fit
in my car bought to because I'm and
they're all sliced into actually this is
wrong they're sliced into six slices and
these are enormous pizzas right so when
they're only six slices each slice is
literally like the size of a plate okay
so it's like okay here's your one slice
okay no he's all we did I told you I had
two pizzas so I had 12 slices of pizza
12 slices and then I wanted to know well
how many slices of pizza can each person
have and there were six adults there so
I was like 12 divided by 6
okay everyone could have two pieces easy
okay 12 divided by 6 equals
- okay now these are what math problems
world like for centuries
right there problems where you know what
everything is equal to and you have a
problem and you can work with those
numbers and you could come up with an
answer okay
algebra is a game-changer because is
where people realize wait a second you
can have a problem where you don't know
what the numbers are well you can like I
don't know how many pieces of pizza
maybe I want to know how many piece of
pizza I should buy right and I know that
I'm gonna have to divide it by six and
then I want say say I want you know five
slices for everyone because it's gonna
be some very hungry people or something
like that right this idea that you
cannot know what the peak the numbers
are like maybe I don't know how many
pizzas there are and maybe I don't even
know how many slices they can be sliced
into but if I want something I can still
work with these numbers even though I
don't know what they equal to that's the
game-changing idea behind algebra okay
which is why I eat algebra and this is a
little subheads you can make the key
idea is that other starts with the V
anyone remember what the word is in
algebra they're called variables
variables okay so write that down that's
something question okay yeah sure so we
come to this idea why do we have our
intercom okay maybe this is a good
opportunity for me to explain um it was
a bit weird
in that it's an Arabic word the reason
why is if you think about all of the
other words you know and how we learn
things right think of all the words like
attached to subjects like like geography
or mathematics or even within
mathematics like geometries and
trigonometry or like I mean all these
words all these words they all come from
Latin now maybe you like your so lots of
things come from one that makes sense
because as as like society Western
society was growing up all the people
who were like scholars and people who
went to school
learn they all word in Latin so it makes
sense that all of our learning words and
school words come from Latin okay but
this guy comes from another language
entirely right it's because for
centuries we weren't doing maths like
this but we saw that these guys were and
like a game-changer does it doesn't
necessarily make things harder it opens
up a whole bunch of harder problems that
you couldn't touch at all unless you
knew this right so the reason why
algebra is harder is because it's a
little bit like well it's a little bit
like the way driving driving is harder
than walking oh I have to learn driving
well because you can go all these
different places if you can try it but
you can't go if you can walk and in the
same way
flying a plane is harder than driving a
car because fly a plane can take you all
these different places that drive your
car cut does that answer your question
okay so the head of you make was
variables and next to that you can put
another name for the same theme which is
pretty rules so this whole idea of
algebra is solving problems where you
don't know what the numbers are right
but you can see it start to gets higher
so I think every time you don't know
what a number is you provide a question
by right we've got different numbers
that we don't know what they are so I
need to be able to distinguish between
them and that's what Pro noodles and
variables are about okay so for example
you know the most common variable is X
very good now I'll tell you another
story another time about why it's X okay
but it's why we have things you know it
basically means unknown like it's
something but I don't know what it is
which is why by the way just as a side
note it's why x-rays are called x-rays
because when they were discovered they
were a kind of radiation and they were
like I don't know the kind of radiation
we don't know anything about it's not
visible infrared snot UV it's something
else
unknown so they called them x-rays and
then the name just kind of stuck
even after we found out what
what are they okay you can get your
science class okay
so simple idea right if we say X is some
kind of number right we're called a
variable because what it can change
right just like the number of pizzas you
buy it can change it can vary so what's
variable right we use the per in room X
to stand for that okay so we could write
for instance X divided by 4 equals 4
right so there's some number in this
case right that if I stick it in here it
will equal 4 and that's called solving
this equation what is the number you
divide by its 16 very good ready
oh yeah sure okay that's that's a good
thing to measure so there's lots of ways
to write x like you might write an X
like this I'm going to encourage you to
even though I didn't there I'm going to
discourage you from writing X like that
the reason why is because that looks
exactly the same as a multiplication
sign right at times so that's exactly
right so I think um this is this is not
that good I mean if you have a look down
there right you can see it's kind of
unambiguous what I mean here which is
why I could kind of get away with it but
when we write equations and expressions
in solar it's probably better not to
writing like this here are my
suggestions you can write like this
that's kind of like I see in a backward
see next to each other or alternatively
you can write it with like a kind of
Wiggly like a multiplication sign one of
the scientists like kind of tails oh my
dog sir I think these are these are
better you'll be able to tell them apart
ok so if you're a bedbug is a bit of
shorthand you can use for example
instead of say 5 times X we tend to
write that just as 5 X right so rather
than saying for example you know five
five five boxes of pizza you could just
five pizzas right it's the same kind of
contraction just making things faster
yeah that's right it's not that bad okay
that you can combine all kinds of other
operations and order of operations is
still the same so for example if I
showed you this 5x minus 4 right which
operation would you do first think about
carefully yeah today okay well if I knew
what this number was right when they say
X is equal to 2 might be equal to
something else because variable but
let's say that well okay so remember
then 5x is short for five times X right
it's not five and a number like their
digits okay
this multiplication happening in there
so therefore this really is five equals
five times two minus one so now you can
see which operation you should do first
right you should do the multiplication
ten minus four so that's six okay is
that make sense